well Harlan County and tedamy
a couple of places you know the world
has two centers when is Stanley on the
other
understand
they say in Harlan County really working
with people
one of the creatures I mean this place
has made me much more than I've made it
well you know very well that all you had
to do is beckoned and then and I run
anyway I well thank you and it's so good
to meet you all and I haven't really
prepared a presentation because whenever
I start thinking about these things
there are so many ways that they have
really shaped my life and my thinking
and my experience that I don't really
know how to start so I'll play by ear
and then fortunately we have time for
questions discussions contributions
criticism and the first thought the
thing that occurred to me when thinking
about how do I talk about the Harlan
County project in in an institute which
is about space and I had to afford a
random thoughts the first random thought
is
my research on in Harlow has usually
piggybacked on the fact that I was
coming here because I could never
persuade my Department the English
department in the University of Rome
that there are cattle seats in the
United States which you cannot reach by
public transportation there is no way
you can go to Harlem on a bus on a train
on an airplane no way
in fact I recently found out that there
is note that there is really no way
other than an airplane to go from
Lexington to Louisville in Kentucky so
one of the things that I don't know what
to make of this but clearly the it does
go bad on the one hand to the mythology
part mythology about Appalachia as an
isolated place a place beyond the
mountains self-enclosed valleys and
things like that
which it never really was a hundred
percent isolated because there are books
that show how Appalachia was part of the
world commodities market ever since the
18th century and so on and so forth
however the fact that it's still hard to
reach suggests that it's a different
type of place from say Chicago or
Louisville or or New York and in fact
after a few years in which I'd been
doing this working in Harlan County and
everybody had been absolutely friendly
and helpful and and the image in the
stereotype there is that well when I my
close friends from Los Angeles when I
was
and it changed student there and I email
know there was before email I wrote her
you know there was a world before email
so I've sent her a letter and said I'm
going to do this project in Harlan
County thank you actually I said I've
been to Lexington Kentucky and she wrote
back and she said they
oh it's dangerous they killed
sociologists there and I wrote back I'm
not a sociologist but basically what had
happened is that this Canadian
documentary Hyuga Connor I think his
name was what actually killed for taking
some photographs without asking the
owner's permission and and there was a
rebellion all over in the public opinion
about all these foreigners coming over
and stereotyping the place Appalachia
has been putting from memory
Don West who was a political organizer
in the 30s and that dist preacher and
the poet has been mission Erised and
duck patched and romanticized an elk apt
to death and so after a while I asked
one of my interviewees she's her name is
Mildred Shackleford and she is she used
to work in the mines and she's also poet
they asked her why is everybody being so
nice to me and they and that was one of
the great lessons in oral history so
I'll read you her answer because it has
to do with place I usually say it's an
answer in two parts that usually
concentrate on the second part but it's
really the first part that I'm
interested in and it says well I'll tell
you something else that makes a lot of
difference you're not from the United
States you're not from New York when
you're not from Chicago
oh you're not from Louisville and you're
not from Lexington or Knoxville
so say you mean I I'm not from where
power comes from and she says yes and
then she says now if you were from Wales
and you were a coal miner and you come
to Harlan County and you was talking to
these people about coal mining they
wouldn't resent you are you're not
trying to influence people or anything
all you're doing is trying to gather a
little knowledge or get people to tell
you stories and they don't present it
now what she's talking about is on the
one hand the relationship of power the
culture of you know the cultural capital
which is at stake in the interview and
and what she's talking about is of
course what I you know the great lesson
is the interviewee always knows more
than you do otherwise you wouldn't be
doing the interview at least above the
subject of the interview and so and then
what I had to offer there was really my
two things my ignorance and my
willingness to listen and to learn and I
only later realized that when I talk to
people I call them everything and what
just came natural to me was to say I'm
here to learn about the history in the
culture of this place and I wonder if
you would talk to me basically and I had
never really given much thought to the
fact that I was using the word learn
rather than the word study which was
featured in the first racist Appalachian
joke that I ever heard and which I will
not repeat unless asked and so the idea
was you know that these people have
really felt like a butterfly with a pain
in it which is a metaphor I'm going to
use very often from now on and
if I can borrow it you know these people
really felt have felt throughout history
like butterflies with a pen in it and
and the relationship of power came to a
great extent in terms of relationship of
space a relationship between the world
metropolis and the colonies because the
most powerful tool for sociological
interpretation of Appalachian history
and the current society has been the
so-called internal periphery theory
which was that basic internal
colonialism and internal periphery that
basically Atlanta was a place that was
being used as a colony to extract raw
materials coal of course but not just
coal wood lumber before even before
called natural gas and as one teacher in
the local community college by led to me
people he talked about the brain drain
the intelligent young people from Harlan
County that migrated they said we're
exporting all our resources and until
quite recently well and to a large
extent today there were fortunes huge
fortunes being made in Appalachia but
taxes were being paid there you know the
coal companies would take their profits
elsewhere and they may be taxed in
Chicago or Louisville or Lexington / New
York and the communities far is left
with a very low tax base totally damaged
environment and people and of course
very poor services very poor schools
because they're based on those local tax
base so this relationship this
particular place with with the
metropolis with with the rest of the
nation interested me
partly because for all these reasons and
in fact but also because there's an
article by on there to echo and that to
echo is this
well he's written the name of the Rose
but he is important for other reasons is
he's a major technologist and everything
and he had an article about Italy as a
periphery of the Empire so in fact the
first paper I wrote about this was
called to peripheries talked to each
other and how they relate to each other
and how some models that have been
developed to explain but basically to
stigmatize southern Italian culture like
the model the so called
amoral familism there was a way that the
American sociologist Banfield
explained Lucania in southern Italy I
found that you know it's the typical
blame-the-victim
you know they're poor because there's
something wrong in their culture that
makes them poor and I found that this
model was being applied also to Atlanta
because the first one of the things is
these people both cultures care very
much about family for one thing and and
both cultures have a very very
complicated relationship to the state
and in both cultures you have these
local elites that act as brokers between
the state and the people and generate
all sorts of corruption nepotism and so
on so there was one one of those
thoughts then I had about Appalachian
space
the literal random so the other stuff
was reason I got interested in
appalachia was that in 1968 where so
many things began I was staying with
Barbara Dayne in Brooklyn Barbara Dayne
in the 50s was described by she's white
she's a blue-eyed blonde lady from
Detroit and her grandmother was from
Harlan it turns out and she was
described by a Bini as the greatest
blues singer after Billie Holiday and
she gave it up to st. protest songs in
60s so I was staying at her house and
she made a tape for me and well a song
she sang was a song from Harlan County
by Sarah oak and gunning and the song
was I hate the capitalist system and I
thought I don't realize that people
might in this country I'd ever he
uttered such words where'd she come from
and and she said Harlan and I realized
that I I was beginning to reason I'm
here I started out being interested in
American folk songs and reason I was
interested in American folk song was
that I was interested in in the b-sides
of the other records in the 50s which
means the countryside's and everything
so and I realized I had a record that I
hadn't paid much attention to with a
song that said they say in Harlan County
there are no neutrals there which side
are you on which side are you on
so I said there must be something to
this place and I started finding out and
I was able to I was invited by somebody
to just take a ride through there in the
early 70s there was a big strike going
going on the strike unless you've seen
the film did some Oscar and Academy
Award winning documentary Harlan County
USA by Barbara Kopple and it's about a
strike in 73 74
and the friend that was driving me
around showed me took me around we went
and talked to people who were involved
in the strike and I didn't understand a
word
somebody talked about accents and but
their accent is different from mine and
very was fascinating and and I thought I
would like to go back I thought it would
like to go back and when I went back I
went back basically after I had begun my
other major oral history project and
which was this project in tetany tyranny
is a steel town interestingly it's a
steel town within Valley in Umbria which
is the center of Italy it's 60 miles
north of Rome but I was born in raw
matter I grew up there and it's done and
and the reason I did this project in
Germany was that I had started doing
you're collecting folk songs industrial
folk song folk songs about the
resistance but in entertaining and after
a while I realized that people didn't
just sing the songs they also told the
stories about them and the stories were
very interesting and so I sort of
started getting interested in the
stories in oral history but what had
drawn me to tyranny was the fact that
just as in Harlan you had traditional
musical forms like very arcade
polyphonic singing about harvest or
things like that that were being reused
to sing about stripes to sing about the
unions and this was exactly what was
happening in Harlem where Sarah ogen
could take a song precious memories and
same dreadful memory
or where Florence Reeves could take a
song later Lily's low which is a gospel
song which is based on an old Bala tune
Jack Monroe and right which side are you
on and my interpretation of this was
both places or industrial places however
in both places industry was not
developed gradually over time by local
forces in both places industry was
dropped wholesale from outside and which
means that the shift from the rural to
the industrial culture was very quick it
was very traumatic but also people don't
have time to forget their rural heritage
so they still had the songs that they
could and they still have the power of
song they could still sing they could
still they still valued self-expression
and they used it for to express you know
the changes and so that there you had a
process of modernization where modernity
was being reinterpreted and redefined in
the terms of a still thriving
traditional culture and he had all these
incredible songs this this incredible
tradition of music that of course
flourished in the 30s because that's
when urban intellectuals like Theodore
Dreiser on one end and Pete Seeger and
the other connected to Heartland but it
still goes on it still goes on if you go
to Harlem now every house has a musical
instrument of course every church has
hundreds of great singers and musicians
and
songs are still being made by local
people about strip-mining about
mountaintop removal by the environment
and things like that so that was the
other thing you know this this place
where modernity was dropped wholesale
and the traditional culture was not
forgotten but it was used as a way to
express the experience of modernization
if you've seen if you have seen the
Barbara Kopple movie Harlan County USA
maybe the most moving moment is when
there's a funeral of people killed in
the mines and then Phyllis bones and
Nimrod workmen they're not from Harlan
they're from Tennessee he is a former
coal miner they saying Oh death which is
this extraordinary of chilling spiritual
about death spare me over for another
year and clearly they're using this old
spiritual which Alan Lomax collect
collected from beer halls but woman in
Alabama in that it's you know he's both
like a white tradition to talk about
death in the coal mines and not just you
know natural death and there was another
thing
and the third thought was Harlan County
USA what does it mean you know the
question was because somehow the title
of the film suggests that there's a
relationship between Harlan and the USA
but it doesn't tell doesn't tell us what
and of course is Harlan typical of the
United States is all the United States
like that of course not
is it an oxymoron which is sometimes you
find in this country where something
wrong happens and they say this is not
the USA I can think of a song by can't
remember who but it's a song about a
lynching in the South Moore row North
Carolina I think and the Sun sets Monroe
fat is more broad part of the United
States or feelings about again the side
the racist incidents in the south and it
says Mississippi find yourself another
country to to be forbidden to be part of
and of course listening to their song is
it what other country what else maybe
South Africa but you know where else so
is that an exception or is it the kind
of exception that the kind of Pathology
quote quote quote quote quote unquote
pathology that tells you a lot about the
physiology and because where else but
Harlan County do we find that kind of
historical experience not that we don't
find exploitation of course trust
violence you know struggle all over but
the forms that it takes are specific to
the to the United States the
Harlan County's on the one hand it's the
south but to me it's more like the
frontier to me part of the tradition of
the isolation has been well a sort of
weakness of the law in a way it's not
very much different from Sicily today
you know where the state and the law
have been absent weak or oppressive and
somehow conflict has taken forms that
are derived from this kind of experience
and also where you know the type of
class relationships are so different
tell you a little story my first
research visit you know I went there in
in 73 and then I have to remember to
tell you a little story about 73 but I
went back in 86 and I went to Lynch now
Lynch that you go over Black Mountain
which is the tallest mountain it can
take him and there's a sign welcome to
Kentucky and it's got a horse because of
course Kentucky is the Bluegrass State
and the horse is riddled with bullets
you know so welcome to Kentucky then
what do you expect
then you go to Lynch it leaches a model
a coal town and it's really lovely
it's a very decent is very well-kept and
and everything it was however a number
of people that you've talked to it said
well this place used to be like a
concentration camp because that's that's
one of the metaphors that are often used
about
you know the cold camps you could you
couldn't get get out it couldn't come in
it was fenced in and so I started
talking to people and doing interviews
and I was talking to this man
an old black miner who wore a baseball
cap that said God guts and guns made the
UMWA and and he told me horror stories
about what had been happening so I said
do you mind if we do an interview yes
sorry went over like a block from where
I was staying at his friends house got
my tape recorder went back turn tape
recorder on and said no you were telling
me what this place was I was pretty nice
they were treating us well and and it
was a great lesson because of course I
realized that when I was doing the same
kind of interviews in tyranny with the
Italian steel workers they would tell
you the stories they would say on tape
would be much more negative than the
stories they would say in conversation
because because usually it's Italy and
this is the United States and because
where is the source of dignity identity
and pride in working class people in the
case of Italy it used to come now which
I'm still talking like a 50s 60s 70s
person my room about 90s and 202
thousands but we you it used to come
from the fact that they had tried to
exploit him they had done terrible
things to you but you fought back but
you fought back and you fought back with
the Union you fought back with the party
which no longer exists
and so that in order to enhance the
image of pride and dignity that you're
projecting you make conditions much
starker than they really were for
instance you forget to mention that yes
you were working in the factory you were
being exploited and so on and so forth
but your wife had a little store on the
side that on the one on the other hand
reason why you could go on strike is
that your wife had a little store on the
side but you would have mentioned this
or because of course that's that's where
your dignity came from in Harlem and I
think this has to do with two influences
in Italy one of which is disappearing
and it's Marxism and the other is it's
turning sour and it's Catholicism but
both put a prize in the poor the
exploited the victims are always either
revolutionary or virtuous or both here I
mean here I keep trying you know I
should mention that what I get paid for
is to teach American literature
yes and I keep trying to explain to my
students how Puritanism works and I have
a lot of admiration being a non-believer
I can afford to have a lot of respect
and admiration for the Puritans and and
the great difference there is in a way
that if success is a sign of grace and
making this much simpler than it is then
then the victim then the poor well they
have something wrong with them so that
your
pride comes from not having been from
not being poor from not having been
exploited for not being a victim and
because you don't have this category
well because the category of class is
not a category that is often used the
this becomes very much a matter of
individual dignity I have this great
interview with this lady that says and I
asked her well what was it like to live
in the coal camp Oh real nice unless she
goes on and you know you breathe the
coal dust from morning tonight and
you're you never knew if your husband
came home at night and and so on and so
forth but the Lord has helped us we had
a pretty good life and maybe they did I
mean you know but in order to say this
and they may have had a pretty good life
because of family because because of so
many other things because of the beauty
of nature around them but basically you
know you know the key passage in that
interview was of course you know they
probably had all the power everything
but if you were a good worker you don't
have any trouble and which means that
your dignity came from on the one hand
doing your doing your job which you also
find a lot in the old-time communist
workers in Italy but also came from
being recognized as doing your job well
which of course reminds me of the
wonderful passage in the autobiography
of Benjamin Franklin where he talks
about how
first of all you've got to be a good
worker
number two you must be if you're working
when you were do work as close to the
public highway as possible so that
people can see that you're a good worker
and and it feeds into industrial
relationships as well meaning that but
we until maybe ten years ago fifteen
years ago the model for the unions in
Italy was conflict and here the model
for the union has always been Union
recognition the Union exists that if the
employer recognizes it and and therefore
the inevitable relationship between the
inevitable coexistence non conflictual
coexistence like in the case of the
mining industry the one thing that
really shocked me was when I found out
that the miners pension healthy
retirement fund which number one I come
from a from a country in which not many
things work well and our public health
system doesn't work well but we have a
public health system and you know yes
you know what a lot of things that we
take as rights like being able to reach
the county seat of public transportation
this is a civil right to us health care
is a civil right there's a different
definition rights here so first of all I
really you know I was I found out that
health care was a privilege and you had
it because we're you you were a coal
miner and a member of the Union but the
way and was administered by the Union
not by the state but the way it was
funded was by a royalty on each ton of
coal extracted which means that the
Union has a stake in the production of
coal and that and that a strike harms
the union's chest as much as it does in
the company so that the strike becomes
very much at this point throughout the
60s and savings strikes were like
dancing both sides went through the
steps but that basically they had a
basic shared interest and this model is
growing in Italy now but but you know
the G political experience to us in
terms of unions was late sixties early
seventies when the idea was now conflict
not mutual recognition so these are the
few random thoughts that came to me as I
was thinking you know in terms of space
the little story about 1973 1973 my
friend David was I was I was too shy to
turn the tape recorder on whenever we
went to see these peoples and but at one
point we finally went to visit this
magnificent woman granny Hagar Frances
Hagar granny means
women that helped in the help in
childbirth and granny Hagar had been in
everything since the thirties she'd been
in the Battle of everett's which was the
great battle good union battle she'd
been in all the strikes and everything
and I didn't I could understand about
maybe 15% of what she said but finally I
got my courage up and I said can I do
you mind if I turn a tape recorder on
she didn't and she was talking about the
roving pickets which was this mass
rank-and-file rebellion in the mid 60's
in which miners
rebelled against the Union that had they
was taken away their health cards but
fought back by blowing up coal mines and
nipples and things like that she was she
was in it too she was one of the leaders
and then she said and I've got scars all
over my body that I can show you I've
got in Harlan and on my legs and on my
arms where the scabs would try to back
us off the picket line and that here
play seven guess you can see it too did
the white place that they prick the skin
apt like that and one man hell did I'd
held my hand and had them cut the whole
chunk out of my hand and this right here
the doctor wants they were afraid of
cancer but that is where they had the
cigar to my hand until it burned out
most through here and my friend David
Walsh as they was in Harlem the
interview was in Perry County across and
she said yeah in the early 30s and I've
got scars all over my lids you can see
them to get read there's a sunken place
and there's a scar and I got scars on my
body where that they take knifepoint you
know sharp knife points and just barely
stick it through the skin where it hurt
and twisted
he says first it that way it makes a
small hole now that's what we went
through without trying to organize try
to get something out of them for the
people so you talk of space and it's as
if this woman's body was a space in
which the whole history of the struggle
in Appalachia has been etched and and I
remember driving through Letcher County
Perry County Harlan County
Knott County where when strip mining has
left have left its mark on them on on
the hills on the earth and thinking all
right this whole all these mountains are
like granny Hagar's body they have scars
on them and in fact this metaphor of the
scars is a metaphor that a number of
people in the environmental anti strip
mining movement use that and they found
that they do they also use other
metaphors like homemade Vietnam like a
bull's cape but the scars the scars
because again that's the other thought I
had about place because there is the
kind of relationship that people have
with place there it's very deep it's
very deep on the on the one hand
it's a little bit like ours I mean you
can be four generations away but you're
still from Sicily and although I've
three generations away and I don't think
of myself as being from Sicily but
that's another story
but they're like us in the sense that
geographical mobility migrations like
you know
Sicilians migrate to Germany the
Calabrese migrate to Belgium and even
those who migrated to the United States
they always did with the thought of
going back of going home in until until
they were allowed to vote where they
live
Italian workers came back from Germany
Belgium France to Italy to vote every
year so as opposed to the dominant image
of Geographic mobility in the United
States where people are supposed to be
moving easily and at elections are like
Italians in the sense that downfall or
maybe some you know down some lose maybe
this is this is very much part of being
part of the South though and I can I'm
thinking of a number of stories from
african-american literature where they
people live in Chicago put down homes in
Carolina and Appalachians
in the first years of migration in the
mid-50s I have this union organizer for
Chicago ed said Loski was a leader in
the opposition to the United Steel
Workers Union told me he said he was
living in Chicago near the highway and
he said every Friday you could see the
lines of cars heading south and every
Sunday night you could see the lines of
cars driving back you know people would
go home every weekend every weekend I
can also think of how this changed this
man he talks about how says his brothers
went to Chicago and they would come back
pat you on the head
give you a dollar and then the year
later they came and they they they left
with plastic bags and the the and a year
later they came back and they had
suitcases they fetch on the head and
they give you fifty cents and then the
year later they came back they didn't
pat you on the head
they were ashamed to eat with you
because they thought you were nasty
people and they didn't give you a Centon
and then later name they never came back
so there is such a thing as not related
to a home anymore
but the idea that you start out and you
want to go back and this is still home
is is is very powerful it's very
powerful
and and I I've done a lot a number of
interviews in Michigan and Ohio with
migrants and and they all you know had
this sense that that's home they may
have been living in the epsilon T
Michigan for 20 years but it's home okay
and then
and this very deep relationship to the
other place
it's unlike ours because the there is a
strong attachment to the place to the
physical the quality of the place
there's a
there's there are scars on the hills
near Daphne as well because people don't
seem to mind people don't seem to mind
yeah it's ugly but we need it because we
need to keep this concrete factory going
and it's jobs and and the sense of place
is more like language we speak or the
people that we know or in the case of
Tarun it's interesting because of reason
they love being internally young people
is that it's so easy to get away from
and all the interesting places are when
they reach but it's not a center for
anything in in Kentucky no pledge and
Harlan you know the trees the water the
mountains are very much a part of the
view of the sense of place and there's
this lady
hazel King she's passed away now in her
70s
she started literally climbing up the
hills to find and Dino's environmental
damage from strip mining she actually
she was the first person in the United
States that managed to get a strip mine
site closed and and she said you know
people tell me don't you feel kind of
suffocated by these mountains you know
one thing about Appalachia is the
mountains are very close together very
steep and the values are very very low
and very very very narrow sometimes you
have room for the creek the highway or
street in the road and sometimes the
railroad
oh and one big difference is where do we
build our towns we build on top of the
hills for defense purposes from way back
when each little town was a different
state at war with the next little town
in Appalachia they build towns in a few
flats but their spaces think that they
can find but and she said you know so
this is just kept you know there's a
song that's called you'll never get out
of Harlan alive and it says if Harlan
the Sun comes up at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon and it goes away at 6 because
of course of a lease on there and she
says no I don't feel suffocated or
anything I feel that this is like I feel
embraced I feel that this is like being
in the womb I feel that it keeps me warm
so that damage to the place the
destruction of the of the land is very
much like the ones on granny Hagar's
body I mean I don't think they have they
use this metaphor that's very popular in
the environmental movement's at least in
Europe as the planet there's a living
creature Gaia Gaia but talk practical
purposes the mountains are living earth
and also therefore living beings you
know the birds and they killed and the
creeks and the fish in the creeks and
the wildlife and even the snakes that
part of daily life you know so that the
destruction of the land means also the
destruction of the wildlife which is
something that they've made a living out
of but also something that they relate
as well it's something that they love
basically a lot of the people that I
talk to so you have this relationship
and then I'm not a religious person but
in Harlem I go to church because my
friends go to church because the music
is great and because the preaching is
great because I expect them to start
handling snakes any moment but so far
but I've only seen the seen them carry
the snake in the box but the Lord hasn't
moved them yet and so they always asked
me to testify and how do you testify if
you're a total non believer in Holiness
Church so especially if they know that
you're from Rome and Rome means the
Antichrist so my line usually is well
our number one's the most successful
testimony which was I flew over here and
from a plane I could see the scars on
the mountains and I think it's a sin now
the word sin means something different
from me than it does from them but
basically you know they could relate to
that very much you know holiness
religion and the care of the earth
somehow clicked you know this idea that
here on on earth to take care there's a
song that Jean Ritchie sings Jean
Ritchie is a folk singer she's from
Perry County just across just across the
valley from Harlan and she sings the Sun
where the Lord says you can live in my
garden but please take care of my sheep
and so there's a sense of being
caretakers of the trees of the land and
also the sense that destruction of the
land is a very concrete physical threat
to them that the people in this
particular Church live in a hollow that
had been swept by a flash flood so they
know very well and in fact any Napier
was my was my closest collaborator she
she remember she told talked about going
to a meeting after the flood and people
talked about how the flood had been an
act of God just like the oil spill and
she says of course the rain was an act
of God but it wasn't God that put that
bulldozers on top of them ills and so
they can tell very well you know what
God wants us to do with what humans are
doing to the to the land so that at this
time the the important thing in Harlan
has to do again with space in that you
know you've got Harlem because of all
the great stories about the union's
there's a whole generation that does
that has no experience of the union's
because they have no experience of the
coal mines what what coal mining is
there is this little one-horse fart
mines totally non-union and but they
have the experience of the strict plan
of the stripping and the experience of
the mountaintop people unless you're not
if you all already know what mountaintop
removal is you know you take off the top
of the mountain to gather the coal and
then you throw what they already call
the overburden onto the valley and you
claim that you created flat land so that
people can build factories on it which
never happens
and I feel and this is something that I
would not feel if I hadn't been educated
there that the the calling the earth
burden is blasphemy the earth is not a
burden the earth is the earth and not
especially an environmentalist but you
know Harlan does this kind of things to
you into your mind and unfortunately
because there's no opposition anymore
the the practice of mountaintop removal
has been dominant and one of the ways in
which mountaintop removal is
unchallengeable is that they claim it's
good for to help make the United States
independent of you know foreign oil to
produce energy and so the tone of the
the University of Kentucky is being
largely subsidized by the coal industry
that subsidizes research on turning coal
into fuel or things like that name since
fuel so that so that people can still
drive big automobiles
cheap on homemade fuel out of coal that
comes out of totally destroying one
section of other country and
so what organizing there is in
Appalachian now has to do with the
struggle against mountaintop removal and
strip mining but if you look at the
editorial page of the New York Times
today it has in a tutorial about mining
disaster in West Virginia a couple of
months ago 27 people killed and and it
says that Senator Rockefeller is trying
to help these people these miners being
heard and they're finally for the first
time talking about the real issues of
mine safety which if you were from ways
that we're talking about my safety they
would listen to you and one thing is
Barack Obama when he was a senator he
came from the coal producing state and
he supported legislation in favor of
turning coal into fuel so there has to
be some kind of pressure to make him see
and he's smart enough and generous
enough that he will may be able to say
this but that a lot of the legislation
that has been passed over the 30 years
over the last 30 years about coal mining
is has huge loopholes at best and it has
the interest of the mining industry I
heard a lot more than the industry the
interests of the people in the land and
the Union has been supporting it because
because even five jobs are of on a strip
mine on a mountaintop removal site are
five jobs and because the Union has for
the last six years identified its the
interest of the workers the interest of
the Union with the entrance of the
industry a lot more than with than it
does with the industry of the of the
working people there I think I will stop
here and so we have time for I
I have prepared a totally different kind
of thing